Joe Rogan proposed just such a debate
which is quite fascinating to see how
much attention and how much funding it
garnered uh the debate between you and
Peter jotez why do you think Peter
rejected the offer
I think it's I think you know again I'm
not going to look into his head
but what I will say is if you're a
scientist and you're making public
recommendations based upon what you say
is evidence-based science you ought to
be able to defend that it ought to be
evident defended in a public forum and
you ought to be able to defended against
you know all comers
and you know uh so I I you know if
you're a scientist Science is based on
is rooted in logic and reason and if you
can't use logic and reason to defend
your position
and by the way
I know almost all of the studies
you know I've written books on them and
we've made a big effort to assemble all
the studies on both sides
and so I'm prepared to talk about those
studies and I'm prepared to submit them
in advance you know and uh for each of
the points
and by the way I've done that with Peter
Hotes you know I've I've actually
because I had this um this kind of
informal debate with them
several years ago with them with a
referee at that time and we were
debating not only by phone but by email
and on those emails every point that he
would make I would cite science and he
could never come back with science you
could never come back with Publications
he would give Publications that had
nothing to do with for example if I'm
aerosol and vaccines Mercury based
vaccines he sent me one time
16 studies to to uh to rebut something
I'd said about thimerosol and not one of
those studies they were all about the
MMR vaccine which doesn't contain
thymaris also it wasn't like a real
debate where you're
you know you're you're using reason and
isolating points and having a you know
irrational discourse I I don't think
that he
I don't blame him for not debating me
because I don't think he has the the
science